Her low freak bitches.
But I also think like,
especially with these videos
that have been coming up,
just women attacking and
like Anthony gets saying,
that woman said that he was going to,
that woman has got like if he called
the police was going to say that he was
raped,
she was raped or you know,
attacking her
or whatever.
That's what he said,
that she said that,
um,
when she was hitting him,
she was saying that she was going to
say that he sexually assaulted her.
Right.
And by the way,
it's the opiate Anthony thing.
That's right.
Yeah.
The opie and Anthony thing,
if you don't know,
um,
our friends open,
Anthony Anthony.
Cool.
Mia was in New York City and he was taking
photographs and they got a photograph
of a woman and this woman got very upset.
He took a photograph of her,
so some sort of an altercation took place.
Um,
some words were exchanged
and she started hitting him.
So she was hitting him.
And if you don't know Anthony,
you don't know that he's a
gun nut and like a legit gun,
not who actually has a license to
conceal carry in New York City,
which is incredibly difficult to obtain.
But here's one strike for,
uh,
people who want people to have guns.
Anthony never pulled out that gun,
never it'd be it.
He obviously felt threatened.
He was getting hit by this one woman who,
Anthony is a nice guy,
but he is,
you know,
51 years old,
loves his drinking and I don't
think he lifts weights that much.
It's not like he's just like big scary,
you know,
Quentin Jackson,
rampage Jackson looking dude,
you know,
he's a,
he's a thin guy.
He's not a,
not a physically imposing guy and this
chick is beaten on him and he's got a gun
on him.
I don't,
I wasn't there.
So obviously I don't know what
the tone of the situation was.
I don't know how it got started.
I don't know.
I've read very little about it other than
he went on this rampage calling her an
animal and a cunt and all this,
all these different,
but what's,
what's hilarious is everything that he
said and his Twitter rampage that they're
firing him before he said on the
radio show and they hired him for
the radio show.
If you paid attention to what he said
over the years and why he's entertaining
and how he says it,
he gets crazy about racial situations.
He gets crazy about certain aspects of
the African American community and he's
done it forever.
And so these things that he said after
getting punched that they were surprising
to serious who had heard him say
these things and they gave him checks.
It's kind of hilarious.
And also like one of the things that
people are pointing out all over la all
over,
um,
the Twitter sphere is they're showing
all these lyrics to rap songs that Sirius
has aired since Anthony
got fired for tweeting.
And the lyrics are ridiculous.
I mean,
oh yeah,
dude,
it's hardcore rap.
They,
they air hardcore rap lyrics.
So they've got,
you know,
nigger this and shoot,
suck my dick and this bitch that
pitches and you know that the craziest,
most radical,
you know,
hip hop shit.
And yet Anthony gets in trouble for this
thing that he did where he went on his
Twitter rampage and said
a bunch of shit that he's,
I bet you could.
I bet if someone was a
real opie and Anthony Fan,
you could probably go back through all
the opiate Anthony shows and pieced
together him actually saying those
words that are in those tweets
that's serious,
makes money off of racist.
That's serious.
Makes money off of it.
Well,
you know what man,
here's the thing.
Um,
I think what happens is that
these companies get really
terrified of the Twitter
storm.
Yeah.
They get like,
you saw that with a,
well,
you see it all the time with
the sponsors for rush Limbaugh,
but you see it with,
or I believe conservative
radio in general.
You see it with,
uh,
like Donald Trump had a,
I forget what it was,
a tie collection or some shit at Macy's.
Then there are all
these people on Twitter,
like tweeting the Macy's account,
like don't support him because I
don't remember what the issue was,
but they,
once it gets going,
the company feels
overwhelmed and they're like,
we have to respond because a thousand
people just retweeted this thing and they,
I think they just feel like the best
route is the 48 laws of power thing where
you just put a head on
the chopping block and,
and think later.
Oh,
I see their point of view.
I do if you,
but I don't think they were fans
of the opie and Anthony Show.
That's what I thinks
part of what's going on.
I don't think they listened.
I think there weren't a
lot of people complaining.
It's just like the money coming in.
It's a great show.
It's the reason why we're doing this show.
The reason why we're doing these
shows because of opie and Anthony.
Oh,
a lot of ways.
There's a direct chain of influences.
Um,
one of them being Tom Green,
Tom Green had his own show in
his house way back in the day.
And I remember going
over there and be like,
this is the craziest shit ever.
He's got server room,
he's got a Goddamn server room with
cables all through his living room and he
turned his living room
into a television show.
He just did a little too early.
He had a great innovative idea.
He did it a little too early.
That influenced us.
Anthony Kumina influenced me greatly
when he did live at the compound.
He did,
he does this thing live at the compound
where he set up a studio in his house in
Long Island and in his,
in his basement,
he has a green screen and he'll
fucking sing while he's holding guns.
Dude,
he's singing songs.
He's singing karaoke while
he's holding assault rifles.
All right.
And that,
I don't know if they have a page,
but that shit is hilarious.
And I saw him doing that while he was
still on opiate Anthony who was doing it
just for fun and I was like,
oh my god,
this is genius.
He set up a green screen.
He set up an a,
a real like professional stage with a
green screen and behind the green screen
he would have like video of
Manhattan or he would have like,
like I was going to
totally steal that idea.
I might still put a green screen behind
me for a w if we do get that tri quarter
cried tri caster thing that we'll do it.
In respect to Anthony,
it's a big part of what they do
and the ethic of the Internet.
It seems to be like the social ethic
seems to be evolving way quicker,
way stronger than at anytime that I can
ever remember in in cultural history.
I never remember these like big movements
shifts and how people talked and
behaved in the words that were accepted
in the words that weren't accepted and
you know,
and just w w just these giant trends
that take place in just wash through
culture.
They didn't,
they didn't move this quick before.
It's because we practice like
a thought mass correction,
which I'm not entirely
convinced it's a good thing yet.
I still haven't really
decided if it's good or bad,
but if you look at that woman who took
the flight from London to South Africa
and tweeted out that
insensitive shit about like,
you know,
like I hope I don't get aids when
I land in Africa or something.
Uh,
she finished it though.
She said just kidding.
I'm white.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
So is he even even worse?
So Buffy were better.
You mean that that's what made it funny.
Before her flight landed in South Africa,
I think she's already lost
her job and the global uproar.
So that person learned that
this is not socially acceptable.
And why did they learn that?
Because the Internet
gave them that lesson.
Well,
she should have been a comedian because
that would have been fucking hilarious.
You know,
if a really funny comedian said that like
a license last year said that when she
went to Africa,
Holy Shit,
that would be funny.
Is it the wrong thing to say?
Yes.
It most certainly.
Yeah.
But if you work in PR for some,
I think it was a,
I don't even want to say the company,
but just a big media company.
So you think she was
on pills or something?
Like why was she fucking say,
I mean,
what did what,
how could a person with in
corporate America thing,
it's okay to put some on your Twitter.
I have no idea.
Kidding.
I'm not,
I'm white.
Lol.
Hope we don't get aids.
Just kidding.
I'm white.
Wow.
Yeah,
that's crazy person.
It's funny though.
Still funny.
It's a horrible thing to say,
but the point is like crazy
people are being called out.
There's still crazy,
but yeah,
we can call them out.
So you're going to ruin a lot.
Good jokes.
You are a lot of jobs.
People are losing their jobs like
Anthony just for going off Twitter.
Well,
you know the,
the Anthony thing is,
um,
it's particularly weird because that's
sort of why he had been known for that.
Like you guys had a
show where it was like,
there were openly joking
about racism all the time.
Like the other day he had Amy
Schumer on one of the best of shows.
It was from years ago and they were
talking about interracial porn and Amy
Schumer was fucking hilarious.
But she was saying that she,
she was so funny.
Man,
it's really fun and she's so sharp.
Um,
she was saying that she's
never fucked a black guy,
but she likes watching
black on white porn and uh,
Anthony was talking about,
uh,
how sad it was and that uh,
his,
uh,
his racism won't let him watch it.
Like his racism won't let him watch,
uh,
a black guy fucking a white girl.
Wait.
There is a certain that is
pretty racist if you can't,
if you can't handle a black
man fucking a white person,
it's pretty,
he's joking.
He is a comedian.
I think a lot of people forget it.
It's a comedy show that he's one
of the funniest people I know.
That just doesn't go on stage.
It's a,
it's a,
yeah.
There's most certainly a comedian,
whether he goes on stage in front of
a live audience or whether he goes,
do you think his rampage was
meant to be funny though?
No.
That's the problem.
That's part of the problem.
That's not,
that's not done for entertainment
or for then you're not,
then your profession
doesn't really matter.
My issue with all these things,
um,
is that like many things in life,
they're not black and white.
You know,
this is not black and white.
I think Anthony is awesome.
I love that dude.
He's one of my favorite
people on radio ever.
He's great.
He's just funny as shit.
He's smart as fuck.
He knows a lot of things
about different things.
He's very,
he's very interesting the
way he looks at the world.
He says a lot of crazy
shit about black people.
He does.
He has for a long time.
I don't know his personal experiences.
I don't know what he's around,
where he's formulated these
ideas about certain black people.
But I also know that he
has a lot of black friends.
Patrice and him were close.
You know,
he's uh,
you know,
black comics that come
on the show all the time,
that a friendly with him.
He's not a mean person.
He's not a bad guy.
If you're a nice person,
he'll be nice to you too.
That said,
I don't know what the
fuck went down that night.
Who knows?
Yeah.
You know,
I mean he did get attacked,
which is just crazy,
but he's leading up to it.
He also used to always talk about
statistics about his city in New York and
stuff like that,
about how,
you know,
Eh,
the,
the race issues with that.
And so I think that what he,
because he didn't,
when he went off,
he didn't really say all blacks are this,
you know,
he was kind of just talking about the
person that attacked and was a savage,
you know,
it was what he said.
He called her a continent,
an animal and all this different shit.
If it was a white chick and
he called her an animal,
he would have been fun.
Yeah.
And we would have called
her the same exact word.
It's,
look,
it's all very tricky.
You know,
when I always say about when,
whenever you see a situation
where two people get into a fight,
it's not always just one guy's fault.
Sometimes it's both guys fault.
Sometimes one a different person.
Like if you talk to this guy,
it would have never turned into a violent
altercation and maybe you would have
walked away shaking hands.
Sorry man.
Ah,
no worries dude.
And another guy talking to the same guy.
It might lead to a bloody fist fight
and it's just a matter of how do you
communicate with people?
Who is this woman?
I've been,
I was in New York City with
this chick that I was dating.
We were walking down the street
and this girl was so nice.
She was so nice.
I mean,
she was,
no,
she wasn't,
she wouldn't be mean to anyone ever.
No mean faces.
She didn't have anything like that in her.
So,
um,
we're walking in,
this black couple is walking in the same
direction and the girl steps in between
her and I and pushes this
girl that I was with.
Just push her move,
bitch.
Just move bitch,
because you know we were walking this
way and they were walking towards us and
she's just decided that that was her spot.
So has she has elbow.
This girl said move bitch.
And she pushed it aside and I am
thinking we're about to go to war.
I'm like,
we're gonna about to go to war.
And I'm the knock out the girl first
because I don't want to have to deal with
her.
Why I'm hitting out of the guy.
I'm like,
this is about to be a fight.
And then the,
that chick just turned went white
bitches or something along the lines like
that,
some white and walked away and kept going.
Fortunately because it was like,
like an all,
all of a sudden I was like,
Damn.
I was like close to a
fist fight for no reason,
you know?
And it just happened to be that chick
was black and it just happened to be the
girl that I was with was white and blonde.
But that happens.
There's black assholes out there just
like there's white hassles out there.
There's Chinese assholes out there,
you know,
that doesn't make me racist.
That makes me scared of people that are
assholes and they come in all forms,
Bro.
I,
I grew up in a Boston neighborhood,
Jamaica.
There was Jamaica plain,
the place where I lived at
before I moved to Newton,
which was our cushy and Nice Jamaica
plain was Phil with his Irish savages.
They were dangerous fucking kids.
These dangerous Irish kids.
And if you ran into him like they,
it didn't matter what race they were,
it's like,
who's the,
who's the savage?
These guilds kids were savages.
Didn't matter if they
were white or Chinese.
You,
you walked down the wrong street in
Chinatown and you run into some crazy
Chinese gang that wants to fuck you up,
you're not happy.
I mean,
it's not,
it's not better that way.
There's all sorts of races.
Every race contains savages.
Every race contains assholes,
you know.
And the problem is when
it's a black person,
it's getting attacked by white guy.
You know,
you gotta be real specific that it's
that person that's a piece of shit.
And if some other people jumped in,
it's them that are pieces of shit.
It's not the whole town.
It's not all black people.
It's not,
you know,
it's just there's a
certain type of person,
whether it's white or black or whatever.
That's a piece of shit,
you know,
and I don't know if it's this lady,
I don't know what,
who knows what happened
to her that that day,
you know,
who knows what happened to her,
who knows what's going on in her life.
And all of a sudden this
guy's taking pictures at her.
She wants to punch him in the face.
Do you remember what time it was?
I,
it was,
I forgot to look to see
actually what time it occurred,
but I think it was around two to
3:00 AM wearing the Twitter happens.
Uh,
but,
uh,
you know,
I understand he's,
if you looked at his photos on Instagram,
he was taking a lot of photos of the city,
a lot of photos of cops and
construction workers and,
and stuff like that.
I get having a great camera,
uh,
that,
that you're playing,
like New York's empty and you're downtown.
And you're taking photo and though
a woman's walking in the distance,
yeah,
you're taking her,
cause it's a photo.
It's,
it's cool.
But,
but,
but you know,
I don't know what happened here,
but what does seem to happen that he,
she did attack him and he didn't have
a police or a deal with the police.
No,
no,
he
doesn't call nine one one because you
figure like they wouldn't do anything
right.
You know,
maybe he's right,
but I don't think the right way to
handle it is going on Twitter and going
fucking crazy.
And I mean,
I think that that's something that someone
does when you just want to lash out.
And for him,
he likes to,
uh,
use social media to,
you know,
to get points across.
And that's a point though.
The black on white violence has been a
point of interest of his for a long time.
You know,
and there's a reality that exists just
like white on black violence exists,
just like all kinds of violence exists.
And Anthony is a guy who was
particularly concerned with that.
It's one of the reasons
why he carries a gun.
Right.
I mean he's a rare person that has a
concealed carry permit in New York City.
He's one of them.
It's pretty hard.
It's got a big ass fucking blue actually,
so let's check hitting him while he's
armed with a deadly weapon and then five
other people jump in apparently.
And the whole thing's chaos and I would
have loved to for it to be avoided,
but I think serious lost the potential
opportunity to engage in a discussion
about this,
about violence in New York City,
about violence in general,
the people interacting with each other
about interacting on social media,
interacting when you're hot with
fucking rage and you're just venting and
ranting and consequently continental and
what is your actual intent and and what
is my job as a representative
of your Sirius Xm?
Am I am allowed to be Anthony or do I
have to be an entity that only thinks like
Sirius XM wants me to think and only
tweets like Sirius XM wants me tweet.
When are you clocked off work?
Exactly know and when,
when,
when are you not,
I'm not supporting him right in this.
I'm saying this is,
this is a very tricky situation where the
company has to be real careful because
part of what you do is you
promote free speech and you,
you have a radio show and you have
this network that's uncensored.
There's net was,
it was the coolest thing about Sirius
was you could get Howard stern on it and
he could swear it was the
greatest thing of all time.
Like from now on,
he's unchained and Opie and Anthony
are unchained and comedy is unchained.
You can watch,
you can hear all my bits.
It's totally uncensored.
They have them on Sirius.
It's beautiful.
So if all of a sudden you decide that you
don't like what a guy says on Twitter,
so his opinions,
which are very similar that
he's voiced on the radio,
very similar,
if not identical,
will now be silenced.
It gets a little squirrely.
The whole thing is a backlash.
It's a backlash to the,
the racism and or implied
racism of his tweets.
You know,
look,
did I do,
I wish that he just went on the radio
and explained himself and more than 140
characters?
Yes.
Cause I bet he could vented the exact
same range the next day with no Twitter
thing and people would not have had a
problem with it if he said it with his
words,
if he explained what happened,
there's a real problem with fucking
getting out anything super important where
you don't want to have any mistakes
and how you're being perceived with 140
characters.
You know,
you're saying cut animal savage,
you don't,
you know,
he's not talking,
he's writing a bunch of shit down.
So you mad that he's
conveying those thoughts.
Do not think that he would have
those thoughts of this chick hit him.
Do you expect them to be,
you know,
Eh,
angelic and his approach to violence?
Like,
I don't know what you're looking for
here because if it's just that you think
that what he said is racist,
have you ever listened to that show?
Because if you listen to that show,
he says like that all the time.
I'll say if you have a job
as a show host or a pundit,
you really need to be allowed to say
what you want on your social media.
Even if it
kind of,
you know,
damages or,
but no,
but,
because look,
if he said all Jews need to be thrown
into an oven and pissed on while they're
on fire.
No,
no,
that's right.
That's a little bit different.
So,
but,
but is it different because where does,
where does one draw the line?
What if he said that and he's only joking?
It turns out he's actually Jewish.
Is that okay?
I don't know nearly enough
about him or the show,
so I really don't know.
I think it's the same thing.
I think when,
when you say something absolutely,
totally awful like that,
like all Jews should be like,
you can't be associated with my company.
Right?
Like you can't,
it's not a serious person at that point.
That's a crazy person.
And it's a dangerous person too,
because who knows what percentage of the
population's listening that's unhinged.
It's been waiting for a
guy like you to come along.
But he didn't do that,
you know?
Well,
he did his respond to a person who
attacked him and then talk in very,
uh,
racial terms about the scenario.
And he has in the past on the
radio show about what it's like to,
uh,
worry about black
violence on white people.
Yeah.
And,
and that's,
what is that like the young Turks,
uh,
thing you saw,
I don't know if you saw that or not,
but that was,
they called them a racist.
That was one of the worst
things I've ever seen.
I lost,
I'm sorry.
All respect for them just based off
of that one interview because it was
completely,
you can know that they
don't know the back story.
They don't know.
They don't listen to the show.
It's an interesting thing though,
isn't it?
When you're,
you're looking at
someone who doesn't know,
Anthony,
doesn't know the show,
doesn't know the backstory
and is responding to just
deciding everything right
there.
You know,
that he was perving and he's taking a
picture of this woman coming up the street
and not knowing about all those other
pictures that he had taken and that he is
an amateur photographer.
He loves taking pictures in a candid
photo of a woman walking down the street.
She's pretty and she had
long legs and just said,
nice body look good.
You know,
I've heard three in the
morning dressed up like street,
absolutely.
Street meat,
dairy,
but,
but they jumped on him
unfairly and that's like,
that was like Fox News.
It was like,
wait,
aren't you supposed to
be the opposite of this?
No,
I don't think it was like Fox News.
I think it was like they
perceived what his word.
I'm telling you there's a fucking real
problem with saying something like that
at 140 characters.
It's stupid.
Like I've said some dumb
shit on Twitter before.
I've had people write full blogs on like
one tweet that I had that it was like a
joke,
just a joke tweet.
I get that.
You could decide that,
you know you have a green
light to write something.
It's 140 characters,
doesn't work.
It doesn't work for anything important.
If you really had a situation where you
thought your life was in danger or you
thought you were,
you know you're going to go unconscious
or you're gonna lose your eyesight,
like apparently had
like spots on his eyes,
wouldn't you want to hear that?
Like the full version of it?
I think if Anthony just would tell the
full version of it on the air and avoid
the tweets,
none of this would've happened so he
wouldn't be able to express himself the
exact same way.
That fucking cunt animal he have
been able to say whatever he wanted.
He would have been able to talk in
depth about black on white violence,
which I'm not saying
that's all that exists.
There's plenty of white on black violence.
There's plenty.
I'm saying that it exists.
I mean to pretend it doesn't exist,
it's pretty silly to me to pretend there's
not black people that will hit white
people and robbed them.
Just like to pretend it's not white people
who will hit black people and robbed
them.
Of course it exists.
Yeah.
Racism exists.
Violent racism from random
people on both sides can end,
does exist.
So is he right in saying that it exists
from them or what do you have to qualify
it first by saying that there's a lot of
piece of shit white people out there as
well.
I don't know.
You know,
I don't know,
but in my opinion with what
they're doing is silly.
This is a quote from Penn Jillette today.
Penn says this.
If I'm in a position where I cross
somebody who was carrying a gun and can,
can defend themselves and hurt me,
and their choice is to write angry stuff
on Twitter instead of fighting me back.
Wonderful.
Gandhi.
That's Gandy.
Yeah.
I don't agree with that.
I think just cause you have a gun that
doesn't make you any more special,
and I'm like,
well,
I didn't use my gun.
It's like,
that shouldn't even be on
the table in the first place.
It certainly should be on the table.
If someone's trying to take your life.
What's the difference between someone
punishing you with her knuckles and
someone beating you to death?
How much,
however much of a background
do you have in violence?
Have you ever seen someone get
knocked unconscious in a street fight?
Uh,
actually yeah,
but on Youtube I've seen in real life
I've seen in real life a few times and
it's terrifying.
I saw in real life once in Hollywood,
there was a a moment in
front of the comedy store,
we're all hanging out.
It was after a show and this guy and
this other guy got in this argument and
there was traffic going by and they're
right in front of the House of Blues,
which is directly across the
street from the comedy store.
And in the middle of this argument there's
back and forth and it's a white guy
and a black guy and you see them start
to like swinging at each other and the
white guy goes into a full panic.
All I remember is this guy like standing
like wincing his eyes and flailing with
his hands like literally had it would
just in full panic and this black eyes,
I see him hit him and I see cars go
in front of it and I don't know what
happened.
I just,
I know that they're,
they're hitting each other because
the white guy was flailing,
but I don't see the connection.
And then the car goes back,
you know,
the car passes and the guys flat out
cold on the concrete just in serious
trouble.
He's in the street.
There's cars going by.
He's in a fight with a guy and he's
completely unconscious and everybody's
screaming.
There's cars honking this
guys out cold on the street.
That guy could die easy.
And again,
we tell you something that
a woman can do that too.
You just like a man can do that to you.
If you don't think that there's women
out there that can punch you in the face
and knock you unconscious because
you never been punched by a,
there's a lot of women that
can punch really fucking hard.
I,
you know this,
see these snacks,
that's my friend Miriam,
Miriam Nakamoto.
She's eight time World Moy Thai champion.
She beat a man and a kickboxing bout.
She's beautiful.
She's a nice person.
She makes snacks.
Now believe that chick
punches you in the face.
You're fucks.
Ceville,
you know,
like for real,
like a regular guy who
doesn't know how to fight,
she'll beat the fucking breaks off you.
It's not not good.
So he doesn't know
anything about this girl.
If the girl starts teeing off on him
with left and rights and she's got like
precision punching,
guess what?
You're going to go unconscious.
Yeah.
So should you applaud him for
night pulling out his gun?
Yeah.
You shouldn't pull out
a gun in that situation.
And he did the right thing
so that I agree with them.
Yeah.
I just wouldn't go as far as
saying that he is a Gandhi.
Like that's I,
he's choking.
Yeah,
I know.
He's twice on it's written.
See when it's written,
you get all fucked up.
You get all fucked up.
Even you the regular person.
Yeah,
of course it's going to get closed.
It's impossible to tell sarcasm.
Like I,
I've thought that he was serious
because he's a pretty serious guy.
Guy Realized that.
He realized he does a
show in Vegas and shit,
but he's very serious.
A lot of serious ideas.
He's serious.
I mean,
he's joking about that
by saying he's gone.
He's premise.
The series,
the premise is absolutely serious.
It's true.
Is there any way to see a security
video of how this went down?
Good question.
Given how serious is a big company,
it's kind of a big implications to
drop one of your biggest host so well.
Their outrage was all over online.
You know what I mean?
People went crazy about it.
Here's going crazy.
There's petitions right now.
They're up to like,
I think last I saw it was 15,000 you know
there's the cancer once canceling it.
They have to be getting hurt by this
because honestly Howard stern and opie and
Anthony,
that's pretty much,
you know,
fueling that channel.
I,
I would imagine.
Do you know that?
For sure because I don't know
what they make their money off.
I have no idea.
I would just be guessing.
Well,
I would imagine that opie and
Anthony has definitely a huge pie.
What's a great Chai
there?
It's a great show and by the way,
if it was on the Internet it would still
be awesome if they just switched to the
Internet.
It'd be huge.
I mean it might be a great
opportunity for them if they meet,
they cancel Anthony if they fire Anthony,
just hope he's still under
contract mean how's that work there?
What Ob said today is that him and Jim
will be back on Monday next Monday.
Well I said they might have,
they might be making it the opn
Jim show just based on contracts,
but what's interesting is is leading up
to this is how much [inaudible] has been
talking about that he's done.
He's not going to sign a contract.
He does.
He wants to do a podcast.
He's done and this whole timing of this
is very interesting because sometimes
that's how the university,
yeah,
it's very interesting.
Very,
very interesting.
Yeah.
Wonder Man,
I hope they do a podcast.
Look,
the show's awesome.
It's funny.
Show to watch little Jimmy.
He's the funniest guy ever on radio.
Jim Norton is my favorite guy
ever of all time on radio.
No question about it.
Consistently comes with the funny,
he's hilarious and he's smart.
He's well thought out.
He's a,
he's an interesting,
he's honest.
I really love Joey.
I think he's a hilarious comedian too.
He's so fun.
Plus he makes me feel,
I don't feel like it's so much of a per,
after I hang out with him,
like I thought my act
at too many Dick Jokes.
Then I went to see him and
I even told them that I go,
dude,
I had the best time that you freed me
in a lot of ways because sometimes I go,
man,
I got so many Dick Jokes.
Why keep writing Dick Jokes?
His whole act was dick
jokes from beginning to end.
And I loved it.
It was awesome.
I saw him at a cobb's Cobb's
comedy club in the Austin,
not cops.
Um,
um,
cap city kept city Comedy Club in Austin.
Anthony's starting as a
compound show this week though.
So that's going to be interesting because
I don't know how if he has a lawyer,
if he said he,
you know he was going to lawyer up if,
but what if he can talk about
and what he can't talk about.
You know it's going to be interesting.
Well I'm pretty sure he could probably
talk about the incident that he could
talk about.
No one can keep you from talking
about a person attacking you.
How could they keep you from doing that?
Any person that could keep you from
doing that is not a person want to be
associated with it.
They fire you for that.
Good.
Imagine someone keeping you from
talking about you being attacked,
like your own personal experience.
How he expresses himself
is entirely up to him.
I think we'll probably get a more balanced
view of it now than when it happened.
You know?
I think he's probably going to
take into consideration all the,
the heat and the bullshit and the time
that's elapsed and the motions that have
relaxed and the tension that's relaxed,
the sting of the punches and he'll be
able to look at it and give you a funny
assessment of it.
But the,
the show would just be better
if they go on the Internet.
They can do whatever they
want a hundred times.
You don't need anybody anymore.
I can move.
You just don't it.
Yeah.
They can move anywhere they want.
You don't need anybody anymore.
It's,
it's silly.
It's like the amount of people that
don't have iPods or iPhones or can't get
their phone to stream through their radio.
It's common almost everybody
now it's really close,
you know?
I mean,
especially if you're commuting,
if you're getting on
subways and shit like that,
and it's actually better than having
some sort of a satellite that sends it to
you and you can get it whenever you want.
You can pause it.
You can listen whenever you want.
It's just a better medium,
you know?
And that don't me wrong.
I have three cars that have
a Sirius satellite radio.
I love it.
It's great.
I love the fact that I
could flip through the,
the shit and listen to new music.
I love that I can,
uh,
get on the classic Vinyl Station
and listened to all classic rock.
Cause I'm old as fuck.
I'm old as fuck.
And I reminisce.
I listen to some Bob Seger.
I like it.
I like serious.
I'll keep it as a product.
But man,
you've got to realize what you're selling.
[inaudible]
okay.